It.
It really,
it's almost like we're dealing with crude tools like we're trying to perform
surgery with hatchets like,
fuck man.
How do you get to those people and have that discussion with all those people?
I mean in terms of there being too much to to talk about and cover.
That's where I do think that things like the New York Times can make a real
contribution because we like there are adults in the room deciding what the
important news is that you should pay attention to.
Yes,
in theory at least.
Well,
no,
I I wholeheartedly agree.
You know,
you're going to learn about the genocide of the weaker Muslims in the New York
Times.
Like if you really read the New York Times every day,
you're going to know a lot about the world and you're going to understand that
the government shutdown is a bigger deal than what happened on the steps of the
Lincoln Memorial.
If you're just trolling through Twitter,
which is how like every person I know,
or Twitter or snapchat or whatever,
like my youngest sister,
how she gets her news,
you're not going to necessarily know that.
That's a real problem.
It is.
I don't know how to solve it other than tell people to subscribe to newspapers,
which still have some standards and which still when they make a mistake,
correct.
The mistake.
How many of those are left?
There's a few.
Yeah.
Um,
I work at one of them.
You work one of them.
You definitely do.
I mean,
look,
I said something to someone from the New York Times Online,
uh,
after,
an article that they wrote about a fight.
There was a boxing match and Conor McGregor and Floyd Mayweather,
we're kind of great.
It was great fight.
Floyd Mayweather schooled him.
Um,
but at the end it said that Conor McGregor,
his face was swollen and bleeding and he was knocked through the ropes.
And uh,
I said,
you can't say that because everybody saw the fight.
That didn't happen in this crazy time where everybody is crying out for fake
news.
You can't say his face was covered in blood when there was no blood.
You can't say that like,
don't do that.
It was it.
Correct.
It,
it was corrected,
which is so rare,
but it's actually not like we correct things.
Yes,
all the time.
Right.
But how do you stop it from happening in the first place?
How do you feel?
The first one?
The first one is really hard.
I mean,
it's blood.
No,
no blood when it doesn't exist.
what I'm saying.
Sorry,
what I'm saying?
It's really hard.
What I mean is journalists just shouldn't make mistakes like that,
but we do.
The difference with the New York Times and any number of these other places is
that we say we made a mistake and we correct.
Well,
it's high.
That matters,
right?
Yeah.
It's couple pros.
It's like someone having getting ahead of themselves,
having a little too much fun.
I don't remember that article.
Well,
it wasn't,
I don't necessarily think it's getting ahead of fiction.
They applied fiction to an actual sport event,
which I thought was bizarre,
but,
but the correct,
and if they did correct it,
well,
here's what's important.
What's important is you can at least get a better version of the facts there,
then you can anywhere else.
Yes,
and I,
I guess there's some people in the new media landscape that I see and I don't
know if it's because they want to sort of gin up their own are what like
nihilistic Lee getting on like using Trumpist language to describe the press.
Would they don't see what they don't know?
I think what they don't understand is that the loss of trust in the press is a
symptom of the loss of trust in lots of public institutions.
The WHO,
you know,
the World Health Organization just came out with this terrifying report.
We're like one of the top 10 threats to health in,
I think the country you should,
we should look this up,
is people who aren't getting vaccines,
people who think vaccines cause autism and are not getting vaccines.
The stakes of like loss of trust in public institutions.
Does it just mean like you're going to like hurt the New York Times bottom line.
It's like a threat to all of our health.
Like quite literally,
you know,
I see these things as being very,
very connected.
So when I see people gleefully celebrating like the fake news of the New York
Times,
I'm like Juva better alternative right now.
You know?
That's what I'm thinking.
Not You,
but
no.
Yeah,
no,
I agree.
I don't understand why anyone would celebrate that.
Think it falls into what we were talking about before that it's a,
an easily digestible ideology that you can just subscribe to.
It's a conglomeration of preformed opinions and you lock in,
you start saying fake news.
And this is,
and it's also,
it's exacerbated by this situation that we find ourselves in where people aren't
really buying newspapers anymore.
You have to get people to subscribe.
I subscribe to several,
um,
on my phone and on my computer and that's how I digest things now.
Or a,
an IPAD.
When you,
you think about what they have to do to get those clicks,
you know,
and you see these weird,
like I look now,
this is not a knock on Forbes.
I think Forbes is an excellent periodical.
They're great.
They,
they,
they write some really important stuff,
but almost every month they'll write this super click baity thing about cell
phones.
Like it comes with a nasty surprise.
The new galaxy s 10 has a nasty surprise and it's so unimaginative.
Yes,
yes.
But to see if he could find how many nasty surprise articles about iPhones and
I've uh,
Ip video game stuff a lot too.
They have like a contributor network that people are just allowed to write
articles on.
Ah,
yeah.
That fucking stuff is so dangerous because as soon as people lose their trust
that you are unbiased and you're giving them an objective perspective on exactly
what's going on.
As soon as,
I mean,
it might be nothing when it comes to galaxy s tens or whatever the fuck they're
talking about.
This has a nasty surprise,
but,
but it,
it flavors your perspective on news.
Of course it does.
And these people are fighting for their life journalists and people in
contributors to these websites and news and newspapers are fighting for life
because everything is dropping off,
the revenues are down,
the revenues are dry.
And then like what's,
what takes their place,
what takes the place bloggers,
who's,
who's looking at them?
Do you share that?
They have journalistic ethics and standards that are like what we would expect
from,
they don't,
they know,
right?
They don't have to,
and this brings you to the [inaudible] Info wars thing,
right?
He,
if he's a journalist and he's definitely not a journalist.
Right?
But this is,
but this is what people are fighting about.
This is,
this is the whole Shebang.
Like if,
if some of that news that you're getting in these traditional venues is fake,
it is dangerous.
If any of it is click baity of any of it is deceptive.
Not agree with you more.
It's fucking dangerous.